merci de m'avoir ça travaille
aujourd'hui pas de travail aujourd'hui
en fait j'ai travaillé dans la nuit ça
fait maintenant un an qu'il n'y a
pratique le métier d'infirmière
clinicienne après un très bref passage
dans le réseau public la santé 3 mois à
peine elle a fait le grand saut dans une
agence de placement personnel j'ai
beaucoup plus de liberté pour concilier
le travail et ma vie privée mais j'ai
aussi un salaire qui est
considérablement surtout pour une
nouvelle infirmière plus grand que ce
que j'avais au public le recours aux
agences est devenu un mode de gestion
mais le gouvernement veut arrêter de
faire appel aux agences privées dans son
projet de loi de 10 présenter mercredi
Québec prévoit interdire l'accès aux
agences de placement de personnel sauf
dans les cas prévus par un règlement du
gouvernement j'ai l'impression que c'est
vraiment abolir sans vraiment trouver
des solutions puissant améliorer les
conditions de travail au public aussi
les infirmières dans l'ordre c'est comme
le bouc émissaire les agences en tant
que tel mais selon moi on est là pour
combler les trous que le public est pas
capable de combler par lui-même pour
nous le projet de loi est-ce que ça
signifie à terme c'est 1900 infirmières
de moins dans le réseau de la santé
plusieurs milliers d'employés d'agences
de moins dans le réseau de la santé et
enseigner sans précédent car la majorité
des membres de l'association des
entreprises privées de personnels
soignants du Québec n'a pas l'intention
de réintégrer le secteur public selon
son président qui estime Quebec
razacible c'est pas la bonne cible et
c'est pas la bonne façon de
d'adresser les enjeux d'attractivité de
rétention du réseau de la santé la
proposition du ministre du B n'a pas
convaincu la figue non plus on a
l'impression que tout d'un coup la
pression redevient uniquement sur nous
pour les réintégrer le rythme des
négociations est trop lent pendant que
sur le terrain les conditions de travail
ne s'améliorent pas l'exode se poursuit
elles ont quitté le réseau public
pourquoi parce que les conditions de
travail étaient exécrables tant et aussi
longtemps que la situation perdurera il
n'y a jamais l'intention de réintégrer
le réseau public elle préfère encore
changer de province ou carrément trouver
une autre profession en dernier choix en
ce moment ça serait le public mais
également ça serait pas ça idéalement on
aurait des meilleures conditions de
travail au public Christian Dubé admaker
changement de culture est nécessaire et
promet qu'il a déjà été entamé avec son
plan santé notamment mais pour y arriver
il invite une fois de plus tous les
acteurs du réseau de la santé a
participé à ces forums de discussion ici
qui me permettra au Canada Montréal